[Music]
music is really really really powerful
in itself and in in what
it can do for you outside of music
[Music]
corogocho is one of the largest slum
neighborhoods in nairobi kenya
but due to extreme poverty there's
limited access to youth arts programs
since 2008 a community program called
ghetto classics has been trying to
change that
my name is elizabeth jorage and i'm the
founder and director of the ghetto
classics program
ghetto classics is a program
that started off here in corogosho it's
about using music to change the lives of
young kenyans and in particular those
from very difficult environments and
backgrounds and lives
horror gosh is hard but we hope that in
our space we are creating a better a
better choreographer
we teach 600 kids a week we have
violence one viola the cellos we have
flute clarinets saxophones tubers
trombones trumpets we only got french
horns the other day which is very
exciting
we see that the discipline that comes
with the kind of music that we teach
in this case classical music
is something very important for these
kids because it's something they may
lack at home so they play together make
music together that gives them family
the lives of the kids are just so so so
difficult the challenges they face
the being crushed by life
having you know no hope and everybody
around you
is just fighting to survive so we hope
that in our space we're creating
a place where dreams
can can be nourished and can grow and be
fulfilled
you